if you redraft the NBA with current
players where'd he take Shaq Shaq
snowing number one overall no chance
what are you talking about Zion
Williamson is about to be number one
overall and I understand that he's got
you know he's got a game or something
like that but come on man no chance Shaq
is not better than Anthony Davis Yanis
Kawhi LeBron James in today's game
you're saying yeah today's game and Greg
Anthony at Greg Anthony 50 again NBA on
TV and tnt NBA TV analyst they're gonna
air eight games over the holiday season
starting this weekend Greg you there
buddy I'm here my man how you doing
did you hear the conversation that we
were just having here I did I thought
out you know what I thought I got
disconnected and I was listening to
somebody else maybe I was having an
out-of-body experience you guys were
saying it Shaq will go six or seven oh I
did not if he not be a lottery thing I
did not I still think was the culprit my
guy Chris Brockman over here
yeah that's be Craig I just think way
today's game is being played like how
does that fit in offensively when teams
are shooting threes a game that's let's
start by saying this Chris first and
foremost rich do you guys drug test make
sure I'm speaking with a rational being
here I think I need to put them on the
Eric Reid plan when you keep saying
stuff like that you know of course it
alters average listen the game has
completely changed and I don't think
people for maybe my generation I
appreciate that
so I absolutely get where you come from
but what you guys got to remember most
people remember Shaq from the three
championships that he won in Layton in
LA and then moving forward but if you go
back to Shaq they watch footage of [ __ ]
coming out of college and when he first
came in the league Shaq was an
incredible physical specimen incredible
physical specimen his ability to run the
floor and finish everything he would
have it would have been different now if
he had been
the guy he was you know late 20s early
30s remember Scheck had gotten a lot
bigger wasn't near the I don't want say
badly but he didn't run the floor and
they would slow the game down for him
but early in his career when you go look
at him when they went to the finals in
in Orlando with Kenny you know guys that
shag would have been a monster even
today because you know the paint still
is there to be dominated and if you look
at Anthony Davis that's what he does he
doesn't in crow Yanis does not shoot
threes
okay so those guys and and you look at
him beat big guys are still extremely
valuable they're just they're aren't we
don't see anybody like Shaq and his gang
Shaq would still be a great force now
later in his career it would have been a
different game he would not have had the
same impact because of how the game is
played it's also believed not it's the
bigger issues back when he played you
didn't run 7080 pick-and-rolls
you didn't have you didn't take forty
fifty threes and and shoot him with the
efficiency that they shoot him today so
that's what the real issues teams would
attack him in his ear all those teams
had big plotting big men that basically
were forced to have to try to guard
check and in today's game team would
flip that they would you know Shaq still
would be effective even you know when he
had gotten a little bigger but the issue
with for Shaq would be eat half that
then go guard those picking roles or
those guards or shooting you know James
Harden they're shooting ten threes
against Tepper he's going to take ten
threes every game James are going to
take eight three eight took 55 three the
other day I mean they're shooting 48
percent from three the last five games
right and you're gonna see them forty
eight and you're gonna see them tonight
in Miami but before we move on to that I
mean do you think we're ever gonna see
teams start to build instead of building
to take advantage of the way the game is
playing today to try and change it back
to the days when you played it that
there's going to be some sort of
reaction
to try and win like the old ways to try
and Pierce this three point extravaganza
by going old-school pounding the rock
down the paint that sort of thing the
Lakers as we all know are playing a
transition game because that's a little
bit more of uh to their strengths than
shooting wide open threes what do you
think reg I don't unless they change the
rules I don't think so
and in part it's because of the skill -
like it's just it's just simple math you
know three beats - so if you think about
like I can shoot 33% from three and
that's equates to 50% right if I take
six shots and I make three of them
that's six points I take six shots and I
made two threes that's six points so and
because teams have become more efficient
at it it's just it's just not going to
happen I don't think and I think you're
going to see more and more of guys that
can shoot and play in space so I don't
see that and then when you look at I get
the opportunity to watch young players
and and what these kids can do today and
the skill level is extraordinary when
you look at middle school high school
what these kids can do and that their
skill sets have all evolved that's just
so I think you're going to continue to
see that and you're going to continue to
see bigger players like a Yanis you've
seen this kid Zion Williams and and how
freakish he is but he's a perimeter
player and so I think you're going to
continue to see that it's just there's
more skill like when we played that this
the skill was obviously very hard but
relative to the skill today I don't
think it could match and so you're gonna
continue to see that you know we talk
about stuff and he's kind of like the
gold standard or the Platinum standard
but if you think about all the top point
guards they all are great shooters
Damian Lillard Kyrie Irving you know
these guys are great shooters from
three-point range
you know and think of what step we step
at 50 50 90 nobody's ever heard like the
gold standard was 50 40 mm-hmm so and
because young people what are they
now that they're going to emulate what
they see and so I don't know that we're
going to go back unless there were some
drastic rule changes and quite frankly
the games getting more populous I don't
see any scenario where they would want
to go away from what the fans in essence
are saying that they enjoy Greg Anthony
here on the Rich Eisen show and you're
referring to what kids are emulating and
how kids are getting better at the high
school and college level are you
referring to your own son Greg you for a
Nicole here no that's a lot of stars
next to his recruit a great kid he's got
cancer you could play we'll see how it
he's got a ways to go we'll see how it
goes but did you see the video of the
plane I'm happy for did you see the
video of LeBron bringing his kid aside
and telling him about all the the the
plays that his kid made that didn't wind
up on the score sheet that made him a
good player did you see that video Greg
bridge I wish I wish all parents would
watch that and understand you it's one
thing that does bother me and like
people talk so much about these kids and
how they're the issues aren't oftentimes
a kid it's a parent and I see it
my old two oldest kids both play it at a
pretty high level and so I get to go and
travel and watch the games and and to
hear how these parents are who
oftentimes don't even know the game or
understand it so to hear LeBron the way
he talked to his son because even his
son didn't get right how important those
plays are and I try to explain to
parents you know the people when your
kid gets old in that first of all your
kids five six years old he ain't going
no damn college ain't nobody recruiting
like let it be a kid and it's ultimately
he develops then we can address that but
you know he's teaching them how to play
how to value the basketball and that's
great advice for it's a great life
lesson to you know not just getting
caught up in the actual numbers it's
about the outcome and I thought it was a
brilliant i retweeted it I wish more
people would see that and understand I
mean it was just incredible and again
I'm the obviously LeBrons IQ he gets
that and and it was awesome to see that
you know and I hope Rick here you're
working hard with your kids to improve
their abilities well
know what we're talking with you know
I'm telling them all the time about you
know their their their level of interest
in whatever they want to do you know it
doesn't have to be sports or anything
like that and that's one of the things
that I really appreciated about LeBron
James is what just sitting there and
talking about fundamentals and offensive
rebounds and it's not stat sheet I mean
it really was something we showed it on
our show yesterday I'm glad that we we
did hit on it and the few minutes I have
left with you here on the show what what
we've seen out of the Rockets again
you're seeing them against the heat
tonight are you still a believer in that
whatever the Warriors have done to lose
11 of their first 32 which is quite a
bit for them even though it's still 10
games of above 500 that they are still
you've got no problems with them that
they're gonna be just hunky-dory when it
all comes down a May and June and
they're gonna hoist the Lombardi again I
mean the the Larry O'Brien trophy good
they're gonna be challenged and I think
part of it it's the same issue that the
rock of they're like everyone's talking
about the problems of the rocket is the
fact that they lost and that is a part
of it but the reality is also that
anytime you've gone to four consecutive
finals one you know three of them like
the Warriors have mentally it's just
harder each year so how how tough was it
last year you think about the last two
years well not the last two but last
year well they had to go to a game seven
you know and then the year before Katie
came here they were down 3-1 in the
conference final right so the mental
fatigue on young steps talked about it's
gonna create a challenge Plus everybody
else is better look how much better
Sacramento is you know look at Denver
like these teams have all gotten better
so now games that you could win when you
didn't play as well a year ago you're
not winning all those games so I still
think they're the favorites and they may
not have the one they may remember
they're going to get boogie cousins back
here probably at the you know started a
new year
they're still going to be the favorite
but they're going to be challenging
teams now have more confidence playing
against them but they're still the gold
standard they are there's no doubt about
it and the East is better so I do think
they're going to be challenged as
no doubt about it but to say that there
anything other than the favor would be
foolhardy I guess last one for you here
just to bring this conversation about
generational basketball a full circle
when noticed again last night when the
Rockets set the record for most
three-pointers made in a game they were
just toasting threes in their final
seconds of a game they could have been
standing there dribbling the the ball
out or even if they did need to get a
shot off they didn't have to keep
hoisting threes to get a record when the
game was over we've seen that quite a
bit this year Jamal Murray hoisting four
for three to get a fifty point night
Kyrie kicked the ball in the stands you
know my question for you is is the game
softer these days because I remember if
anybody tried that against the Knicks
when you were playing that they would
have to face Oakley or somebody or
something like that happening I don't
want to use the word softer because the
honestly the rules are such that they
want to see more skill and they want to
get away from escalating any type of
physical altercations on the floor so I
yeah it's not that I would say softer
but how about we just use it more
politically correct its what more
accepting today of certain behaviors
right
oh that's just James being James why has
it been grass yeah we just weren't we're
just but more accepting society rich you
know I see it all the time I'm watching
you on the NFL show on Sunday awesome
you're just more accepting of behavior
from others that baby wouldn't tolerate
like what you got an example on that
front Greg I mean no I'm more accepting
to I found myself laughing did not even
be upset like last night's a perfect
example 10 years ago it would have
bothered me what Houston did but I
actually was sitting there like are they
gonna get the record I wasn't gonna get
the record like my mind has completely
changed on it I just think young people
and you know younger people growing up
they didn't see that era right like
think about young people today they
didn't even see Michael Jordan play
there's a lot of young people they
didn't see Colby play that's crazy you
know so it's
just this is what this is all they know
and so that's why kids growing up you
don't see these kind of altercation
every time there's a little travel team
game now after the game everybody walks
in online and shakes everybody's hands
you know so it would be different in my
era but that doesn't make my era better
you know people call them the good old
days because they don't want to remember
all the days all of one good Greg thanks
for the call man have a great holiday
have a great call with Kevin Harlan
tonight on TNT down there in Miami you
too my friend you guys be good you got
it
thanking thanks for watching game day
morning Greg I appreciate that the NFL
Network at Greg Anthony 50 the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience